is Twitter taking a lot from Facebook
the quickness of Twitter is such a
factor all of you looked at Twitter and
said what am I gonna say and I said oh
[ __ ] I can see what people are saying
and engage it and that's why I love
Twitter people are in a false sense of
reaching mass audience and Twitter right
now because of this enormous firehose of
data Twitter has a firehose problem
twitter has gotten nosy Twitter is noisy
as hell nothing is more important than
the attention of the end user nothing
the attention of the end user is the
cost of entrance to accomplish anything
twitter struggling people don't
understand it it's losing attention
Instagram and snapchat emerged as major
attention grabbers within mobile devices
the first time I've been able to make
something trend in the last three years
was this August when I sent a snapchat
to 4,000 people and so I took a picture
of myself holding up a bottle of wine
with a hashtag and after those 5,000
people in two seconds a ton of them
posted that picture on Twitter with that
hashtag and I was able to make friend
they'd income limit the things that are
being said or the amount of people if
you don't engage with a single thing
from a person in a year you need to see
every single thing they say and so
they're not playing the attention
arbitrage I mean the amount of people
you follow on Twitter right now that you
don't care about it's stunning and this
is email behavior will unsubscribe we
delete but you're not gonna take the
hour to unfollow it's just the way we do
things we don't purge it's quicker for
us to just go through the stream Twitter
doesn't have an algorithm like Facebook
does for the best content if there's
this person that you have not clicked
through on their tweet for a period time
six months or a year it should be
automatically or at least prompted the
way Facebook handles it the biggest damn
company in the world I think this is the
television and that TV is the radio and
it's 1965 I think this is the number one
device and I think that YouTube Facebook
Instagram and snapchat are NBC NBC and
CBS think of Twitter as MTV what I think
has happened to Twitter is that snapchat
and Instagram have now become ESPN have
now become the hot network the game
is changing quickly and often and if
you're not adjusting you're gonna lose
they didn't ID ate the product for a
long period of time and they're paying
the price I am so intrigued by seeing
what's gonna happen